scientists regularly work with
three-dimensional data for medical
images like MRI scans to maps of
glaciers produced by lasers but most
scientists use flat displays like
computer screens which can't fully
represent 3d datasets so researchers are
looking for newer better ways to display
3d data virtual and augmented reality
systems for example can display
patient's medical images to help doctors
better plan surgery but 3d printing can
also be used to print out physical and
held copies of data these models can
easily be shown to large groups without
VR headsets which makes some people feel
nauseous 3d data needs to be converted
into a computer model before it's
printed these models are made up of tiny
connected triangles with a covered
surface but this process can make for
awkward images for example MRI images of
the fine white matter tracts in the
brain are converted into bulky tubes
this kind of printing also has trouble
creating objects where solid parts or
data points are separated by empty space
now scientists have developed a method
called voxel printing which allows
high-resolution printing of 3d data
without the need to convert it into a
computer model first the 3d dataset is
sliced up into hundreds of horizontal
images each made of thousands of boxes
or three-dimensional pixels each voxel
is printed using droplets of colored
resin which are hardened with UV light
different resins can be combined to
produce new colors and a transparent
resin is used to represent empty space
each layer is printed out one on top of
the other to gradually build up a 3d
structure layers can be as thin as 12
microns the final high-definition model
can contain billions of individual boxes
so far the researchers have used their
technique to print out copies of tissue
samples laser scans statues and Popa
graphical maps of the moon
the ability to faithfully reproduce 3d
data in a physical form that have a
range of applications from conserving
historical artifacts to helping patients
understand their medical scans the team
says that they hope one day scientists
will be able to print off 3d datasets
with just the press of a button
[Music]